five places whose names remind us of
cheese several towns in the Netherlands
have names that immediately remind us of
cheese take Gowda our number five for
example where cow's milk cheese has been
made since the Middle Ages it has made
the town world-famous in fact but beware
these days galder doesn't necessarily
come from the Dutch town of the same
name this cheese was invented in a
village in Normandy France around 1789
during the French Revolution camembert
might be small but it's now a household
name the world over and is fourth in
today's rundown camembert cheese is
still produced the same way it was 200
years ago what's more it still comes in
the traditional wooden boxes despite the
invention of plastic and cardboard
packaging
this small Dutchtown was once a trading
center for fish and cheese and Edom
remains closely associated with cheese
to this day located north of Amsterdam
the town still has a traditional cheese
market incidentally the Dutch usually
eat edem for breakfast and he damn comes
in third place today Switzerland is also
famous as a cheese producing nation and
what more could a dairy cow long for
than some of this luscious grass to this
day many people in the Emmental Valley
earn a living from farming and cheese
making the milk from the dairy cows is
processed in a large number of local
cheese dairies had exported as Emmental
the world over second place goes to
emmett are
this has to be one of the most
frequently imitated and popular kinds of
cheese the world over real cheddar
cheese hails from the village of cheddar
in Somerset in the southwest of England
and it's number one on our list of
cheese making locations but why is it
often orange coloured well the cheese
only turns orange on its own in the
spring that's when the grass is moist
and the milk rich in fat but these days
cheese manufacturers lend a helping hand
and add coloring to make it look
especially appetizing